[موسيقى]
لا تزيد مساحتها كثيرا على 12 كم مربعا
لكنها اصبحت اليوم العنوان الاهم في
يوميات الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا الحديث
هنا عن سوليدار المدينه الصغيره الواقعه
في الشمال الشرقي لمقاطعه دونيتسك احياء
وشوارع سوليدار كانت وما تزال مسرحا من
معارك طاحنا بين الجيش الاوكراني والقوات
الروسيه وتحديدا اكثر مقاتل فاجنر الذين
اصبحوا بمثابه راس الحربه الذي تراهن عليه
موسكو على ما يبدو لتحقيق نصر على ارض
السلدار وباي ثمن لا سيما في ظل
الانتكاسات الميدانيه التي تعرض لها الجيش
الروسي في الاشهر الاخيره ورغم اعلان
المجموعه الروسيه العسكريه الخاصه بان
قواتها احكمه السيطره على المدينه وبانها
قضت على كل من رفض الاستسلام فان اللافته
هناك دعوه لكريم للتلوث قبل اعلان النصر
مع الاشاده بما وصفها بالاعمال البطوليه
لمقاتلي فاجنر على جبهات القتال في حين
صارت قياده العمليات الاوكرانيه للتاكيد
على ان جنودها لا يزالون يخوضون قتالا
شرسا في سندار مع الاعتراف بان الوضع صعب
للغايه خصوصا ان تامين خطوط الامداد بات
امرا عسيرا فالجيش الاوكراني يدرك ان
المعركه هناك لا تتعلق فقط ممن يسيطر على
المدينه التي سوءت غالبيتها بالارض فهي
ايضا تعد بمثابه خط الدفاع الاخير
والبوابه الشماليه لمدينه باخم موت التي
تحاول القوات الروسيه السيطره عليها منذ
الصيف لكنها فشلت لذلك حتى الان
رغم الهجمات الصاروخيه العنيفه والزنج
بمقاتل فاجنر على خطوط القتال الاماميه
قبل ان ترسلهم وسكو لاحقا الى جبهته
السليدار على امل ان يكون هناك بمثابه
اختك تحول المسار الحرب المستمره منذ نحو
320 يوما